vous êtes vice-président de l'université
américain d'Afghanistan à Kaboul vous
êtes une ressortissante française et
vous attendez et vous espérez un jour
qui te raconter moi là où vous en êtes
dans cette démarche
alors je suis bonsoir je suis dans un
campagne près de l'aéroport de
kilomètres et donc j'attends de pouvoir
l'aéroport
[Musique]
désarroi cette accélération l'histoire
est-ce que vous ça vous a surpris la
vitesse avec laquelle les talibans sont
rentrés à Kaboul
totalement il y a une semaine l'autre
bord de nous demander de rentrer et on
leur disait ne vous inquiétez pas ça va
mettre si ça arrive ça mettra quelques
semaines tombera pas et pourtant nous
sommes tous
nous sommes
donc j'ai pensé que
la situation est
travailler collaborer avec les forces de
l'Ouest
écouter je pense pour ce sera quasiment
impossible dans sauver même une partie
un film il faut
dire
qui
c'est
non je pense que c'est une façon
d'essayer de redorer le blason afin
d'obtenir une reconnaissance diplôme
étranger
[Musique]
Kaboul a été prise de force le cas donc
cette reconnaissance internationale
ne dois surtout pas venir et je sais que
le Canada sera au rendez-vous et ne
tombera pas dans le panneau peut-être
dans les maisons ou des gens
travaillaient qu'est-ce qui va arriver
alors déjà ça a commencé
de maison en maison dans certains
quartiers pour voir qui a travaillé pour
les forces occidentales
absolument est le paradoxe de ce qui se
passe en ce moment du fait que toute
cette population a investi le tarmac
quelque part c'est pour faire en sorte
que nous ne partons pas parce que mais
alors c'est pour moi c'est de
l'intelligence collective
dès qu'on sera parti l'épuration va
vraiment commencer
absolument